Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Wir sind zurück in Jena bei Henry, dem Physiker
meines Vertrauens.
Hey Jack, willkommen zurück.
Wie immer testen wir für Euch wie realistisch
Superhelden sind und heute haben wir gleich
mehrere am Start, denn die haben alle was
gemeinsam.
Die haben alle eine Dosis Strahlung abbekommen
und haben dadurch Superkräfte bekommen.
Und ob das funktioniert, ob Radioaktivität
uns Normalos Superkräfte geben könnte,
dass spielen wir heut für Euch durch. Los geht’s.
Henry bevor wir uns konkrete Beispiele anschauen,
sollten wir vielleicht erstmal klären, was Radioaktivität ist.
Radioaktivität ist die Umwandlung von chemischen
Elementen ineinander und dabei geben die radioaktive Strahlung ab.
Wichtig dafür ist der Atomkern.
Der besteht aus elektrisch neutralen Neutronen
und elektrisch positiv geladenen Protonen.
Die Protonen kennen wir aus dem Periodensystem
der Elemente.
Das ist die Ordnungszahl.
Also bei Wasserstoff 1 heißt dann 1 Proton im Kern, bei Helium 2 heißt 2 Protonen im Kern und so weiter. Genau.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch Atomkerne, die haben
die gleiche Anzahl von Protonen aber unterschiedliche
Anzahl von Neutronen. Die nennt man Isotope.
Das ist das gleiche chemische Element aber
mit leicht verändertem Atomkern.
Und es gibt jetzt Atomkerne die haben genau
das richtige Verhältnis zwischen Protonen
und Neutronen – die sind stabil – aber
es gibt auch welche, die haben ein paar zu
viele oder zu wenige Neutronen und die zerfallen
dann eben und geben Strahlung ab.
Ob das aber positive Effekte für unsere Superhelden
haben kann, schauen wir uns an ganz konkreten Beispielen an.
Unsere ersten Testkandidaten sind die Fantastic
Four.
Das ist ein Quartett um den genialen Wissenschaftler
Reed Richards und die bekommen ihre Superkräfte,
als sie sich als Astronauten kurzzeitig im
All aufhalten und dort von kosmischer Strahlung getroffen werden.
Im Film sieht das mega krass aus… Henry
ist das realistisch und was ist eigentlich kosmische Strahlung?
Kosmische Strahlung ist eine Teilchenstrahlung,
sehr hoch energetische Teilchen und die kommt
beispielsweise aus Sonne, von irgendwelchen
weitentfernten Sternen oder aus irgendwelchen Supernovae zu uns.
Ein Teil dieser Strahlung ist eben radioaktiv. Zum Beispiel α- oder β-Strahlung.
Das sind auch sehr schnelle Teilchen.
So krass wie im Film würde man das gar nicht
sehen, weil die radioaktive Strahlung um uns rum sehen wir ja auch nicht.
Man kann sie aber sehen, wenn sie mit der
Erdatmosphäre wechselwirkt.
Beispielsweise bei den Polarlichtern.
Dadurch, dass die Teilchen relativ viel Masse
und Energie haben, können die auch erstmal viel kaputt machen.
Aber beispielsweise unsere Haut oder unsere
Klamotten schirmen die Strahlung schon relativ gut ab.
Wenn man das nicht gerade einatmet oder isst,
droht da erstmal relativ wenig Gefahr.
Grundsätzlich ist es so, je höher man über
den Erdboden kommt, desto mehr kosmische Strahlung bekommt man auch ab.
Bei einem Transatlantikflug bekommt man so
100 µSv ab, beim Hin- und Rückflug.
Sievert ist die Einheit für die Strahlendosis,
dass müssen wir ins Verhältnis setzen…
Was kriegt man so beim Röntgen ab?
Wenn man sich den Brustkorb röntgen lässt,
bekommt man so 20-40 µSv ab.
Die normalen Astronauten sind dieser kosmischen
Strahlung permanent und über einen längeren Zeitraum ausgesetzt.
Ganz genau. Die Astronauten bei einem 6-Monats-Aufenthaltauf der ISS kriegen
so 80.000 µSv – 160.000 µSv Dosis ab.
Das ist schon ordentlich. Genau.
Aber die haben dort Geräte, die permanent
überwachen, wie hoch die Strahlenbelastung ist.
Und die lassen ihr Blut regelmäßig auf Chromosomenschäden
untersuchen – damit da auch alles safe ist.
Aber bei den Fantastic Four ist es so, dass die so kurz dieser kosmischen Strahlung ausgesetzt waren,
dass das eigentlich kaum Effekte haben
sollte.
Das heißt, deren Körper hätte das ganz
normal verarbeitet…
So wie ein Astronautenkörper das auch verarbeitet? Ganz genau.
Denn dabei geht’s nicht um die akute Dosis,
die die abbekommen, sondern um die Exposition.
Das bedeutet wie lang die dieser Strahlung
ausgesetzt sind.
Denn auch bei geringen Dosen steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
für bestimmte Effekte,
je länger man dieser Dosis ausgesetzt ist.
Deswegen macht man sich auch schon Gedanken
über zukünftige Marsmissionen, denn dort
sind die Astronauten eben auch über eine
sehr lange Zeit dieser kosmischen Strahlung
ausgesetzt und damit die safe auf dem Mars
ankommen, muss man da eben schon jetzt drüber
nachdenken und Vorkehrungen treffen.
Also Fazit: Nein, die Fantastic Four hätten
ihre Kräfte nicht aus diesem kosmischen Strahlungssturm bekommen können.
Wir müssen anscheinend die Dosis erhöhen
und das können wir machen… bei unserem
Testkandidaten Nummer 2.
Dem Atomphysiker Bruce Benner.
Der hat eine Bombe entwickelt und stand dummerweise
in der Nähe als die hochgegangen ist und
hat dadurch ne fette Portion Gammastrahlung
abbekommen.
Henry, was ist nun wieder Gammastrahlung?
Gammastrahlung ist die dritte Art der radioaktiven
Strahlung.
Das stimmt. Wir hatten schon α-Strahlung und β-Strahlung – das waren Teilchen γ-Strahlung sind keine Teilchen?
Genau. γ-Strahlung ist elektromagnetische
Strahlung, vergleichbar mit dem sichtbaren
Licht um uns rum.
Aber die γ-Strahlung ist viel energiereicher,
hat eine sehr kleine Wellenlänge, keine Masse
und kann deswegen ziemlich tief ins Gewebe
eindringen und dort Schäden verursachen.
Das kann man eigentlich nur aufwendig mit
Blei oder Beton abschirmen.
Das war bei Bruce Benner nicht der Fall, das
heißt nach so einer Explosion müsste der eigentlich tot sein.
Oder zumindest alle möglichen Symptome der
Strahlenkrankheit zeigen oder Krebs bekommen.
Ganz genau.
Gut in den Comics wird erklärt, das Bruce
Benner jetzt eine nicht weiter erklärte,
genetische Veranlagung dazu hat viel Strahlung
abzukönnen.
Das heißt wenn er das abkann: Könnte die
Strahlung ihm dann Superkräfte geben?
Das können wir einfach mal mit einem Lego
Modell nachstellen.
Ich hab hier mal die Doppelhelix der DNA aus
Lego nachgebaut.
Und wenn jetzt ein Gammaphoton auf diese DNA
trifft – hier nehmen wir dieses Stück Kreide
– dann kann die diese Basenpaare, diese
Klötzchen die zusammenhängen, trennen und
Teile der DNA schädigen.
Das stellen wir sehr nerdig nach…
So Henry, jetzt fehlt hier ein Stück DNA. Was heißt das?
Wenn es der Zufall so will, dann kann diese
Veränderung die Zelle auch gutartig mutieren
lassen und eben auch einen positiven Effekt
erzielen.
Und das hat man sich sogar zu Nutze gemacht.
In den 50ern und 60ern gab es Experimente
mit Pflanzen, da wurden die Samen bestrahlt
und die wurden dann eingebuddelt, die Pflanze
konnte wachsen.
Dann hat man geschaut, ob durch die Bestrahlungen
Mutationen ausgelöst wurden, die der neuen
Pflanze dann positive Eigenschaften gegeben
haben.
Und da gab es dann schädlingsresistenten
Weizen, aber auch… bananenförmige Tomaten.
Jetzt gibt’s aber mehrere Probleme.
Zum einen bekommt man bei einer zufälligen
Bestrahlung nicht nur diesen einen Effekt
den man haben will, sondern auch viele zufällige
unerwünschte Effekte, die man später wieder
aussortieren müsste.
Zum anderen müsste man, beispielsweise bei
Bruce Benner, nicht nur eine Zelle bestrahlen,
sondern eben alle.
Alle? Wie viele sind das bei einem erwachsenen Menschen?
Das sind ungefähr 30 Billionen Zellen. 30 Billionen? Genau.
Und zusätzlich hat die DNA im Zellkern etwa
3 Milliarden Basenpaare.
Okay das heißt also: Damit der Hulk entstehen
kann, müssten wir 30 Billionen Mal die exakt
selbe Stelle im Zellkern treffen, mit unserer
Strahlung?
Ganz genau.
Dazu kommt noch, dass viele Eigeneschaften
die wir haben multifaktoriell sind.
Das bedeutet, die werden nicht nur durch ein
Gen ausgelöst, sondern durch eine Kombination
von vielen Genen.
Und die alle in exakt derselben Weise zu verändern
ist absolut unrealistisch.
Also auch hier: „Sorry Bruce“ aber der
Hulk haut leider nicht hin.
Testkandidat 3 ist Spider-Man und Henry ich
trau mich schon gar nicht mehr zu fragen,
aber hätte wenigstens Peter Parker eine Chance
auf mutierte Superkräfte?
Peter Parker wird von einer radioaktiven Spinne
gebissen und dabei geht das radioaktive Gift
in seinen Körper über.
Aber die Menge des Gifts ist wahrscheinlich
viel zu gering, um alle seine Körperzellen zu verändern.
Zusätzlich haben wir wieder dasselbe Problem
wie beim Hulk, dass ja alle Zellen in der
gleichen Art und Weise verändert werden müssten. Deswegen auch eher unrealistisch.
Dann könnten wir aber wenigstens überlegen,
dass nicht diese radioaktive Substanz in Peter
geht und seine Zellen beeinflusst, sondern
das die Radioaktivität schon die Spinnengene
verändert hat und dann diese veränderten
Spinnengene irgendwie in Peters DNA übergehen.
Also man könnte schon tierische Gene in die
menschliche DNA einbauen.
Das würde funktionieren.
Also man sagt einfach einer bestimmten Zelle,
sie soll jetzt Spinnenseide produzieren und
andere Zellen sollen diese Spinnenseide raus
schießen.
Aber man muss dabei eben aufpassen, dass die
anderen Funktionen der Zelle nicht beeinträchtigt werden.
Und… Ohne Labormethoden und nur durch einen
Spinnenbiss – das halte ich eher für unrealistisch.
Was für eine deprimierende Folge.
Auch Peter Parker hätte keine Chance.
Dabei wäre es so schön, denn wenn Peter
Parker seine Fähigkeiten von der Spinne bekommen
könnte, würden die wieder total gut hinhauen.
Das hat Henry in unserer Folge zu Spider-Man
überprüft.
Die verlinken wir Euch – schaut Euch die
mal an.
Fassen wir zusammen.
Weder die Fantastic Four, noch der Hulk, noch
Spider-Man könnten ihre Superfähigkeiten
durch Radioaktivität bekommen.
Oje...
Ja aber auch irgendwie gut, weil sonst könnte
ja jeder Mitarbeiter in einem Atomkraftwerk
unsichtbar werden oder in Flammen aufgehen. Das hat schon seinen Sinn.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir andere Superhelden
für Euch durchsprechen, dann schreibt uns das in die Kommentare.
Gern auch, wie ihr diese Folge fandet.
Und dann sehen wir uns nächsten Mittwoch
wieder. Ciao!